I think I wanna go to America I wanna  buy fashion clothes like Chanel Versace  and he saw prime know me bring me I  store like that he might lie before  that's ever like that's close I want  clothes elegant clothes nice things like  oh there's four young girls rubbish  that's pretty nice like look at this mr.  boa Tracy I don't I use loans that's  crazy that's okay well corner either  like not be here hey how are you guys  doing finding everything okay yeah fine  they'll find nothing yet nothing yet  take a look around there's gonna be a  lot of different things we buy from the  public every day then we go through it  is you see mm-hmm oh you use clothes do  bring do I use clothes it's still closed  the single condition it's not damaged  [Music]  [Music]